how to decide who to fire so I got a
great question from one of my zuga
customers who bought the guy's name
dieter and he's also been a loyal
YouTube follower and he's basically
asking how do I decide for companies who
to fire
when it's a downturn so here's what he
wrote in having while you're away in
Malaysia I thought about a question when
the company faces tough times internal
crisis or worldwide crisis and must make
it downsizing how do we choose who lose
the company usually downsizing about
money but sometimes the best people are
the ones with the best paychecks should
I fire one person per day or 20 people
per day as you said before first I
should keep the people who have a
passion about my business and then check
the payroll make a decision
what do you think if you'll still got if
you get any of our email or YouTube if
you think this question could help more
entrepreneurs I'm a consultant for small
business companies in Mexico I
understand a lot of what you do because
it's what I do every day I help people
to reach their goals at the same time
I'm searching for my goals and working
so hard every day they create and
establish my company because I feel I'm
gonna be world-class as something else
one day that's why I ask you a lot I
know I can change the world I really
appreciate all your help I began with
nothing only my chemical engineering
degree and my passion no money no
powerful friends no family business no
mentors but what I can tell pretty sure
is that are going to be a massive
success thank you for everything
saludos dieter a great email thank you
so much I'm glad that you've loved the
videos and the Zuka guides that's a it's
a tough question okay laying off people
letting people go is never an easy thing
to do so here a few suggestions for you
okay number one think lifetime so
whenever I create a position in my
company I'm always thinking about having
this role having this person be part of
my business forever from my whole life
now obviously that will change you know
it that person may move on I may decide
that this isn't the right path for us
anymore but I always go in with the
intention of having somebody in that
role having this person who comes on be
a part of my team forever I try to
create a family so when I created this
job for example for a video editor you
know I knew I wanted to make video
I heard Christina you know I want
Christina with me for the further end
until the rest of our days that may not
happen you know Christina may move on
she may find something else she loves
more than doing videos she may get tired
of it I may decide you know what videos
man I'm so tired of these videos and I
can do videos anymore and I may move on
right but I'm going in with the
intention of having that person with me
for the rest of my life
and I think too many times companies
start off and they don't respect the
lives of the employees enough and they
say well I'm gonna hire somebody for six
months and see if it works out or not
and trying out this project er it's just
it's not enough respect and so I would
encourage you to consult with the
clients that you're working with to make
sure that when they're hiring that they
really think like this is the position
we're gonna need for the rest of our
life and we're really gonna value the
employees that we bring on number two
take the first cut yourself whenever
there is a downturn and it's going to
happen in every business it should be
the the owners job I think to take the
first pay cut themselves again I think
of everybody as my family I want them
with me forever I want them to be
passionate what they're doing and I
think about the people being with me the
longest I've never asked anybody to take
a pay cut and I've never fired anybody
for for financial reasons I've never
fired a good person because there was a
downturn I've always found a way to keep
people on board I've never asked people
to take a pay cut but I've taken cuts
you know I got had this business for
four oh I don't know 10 11 12 years
something like that
and I've my income has gone up and down
I've taken huge cuts but I've never
asked people on my team to take a cut
because I feel bad you know like they're
part of my family I know they were lying
on me for their livelihood and I guess
the worst-case scenario would be that
that if I really couldn't afford it
maybe everybody goes down to like four
days a week instead of five days a week
so
like that but but again you have to feel
the pain right like the owner should
love their business so much and care
about their staff so much that they're
willing to take the first cut themselves
before they cut other people's salaries
and the number three you know final
option plan when all else fails is you
know decide where you're going if your
business is not able to financially
support the people on your team anymore
it's because there's something wrong
with your business right the market has
gone down people are buying anymore you
have to save your company and you have
to figure out who has to go but more
importantly what the direction your
business is gonna be because you can't
just keep doing the same things anymore
right that's not working you're in a
downturn you're losing customers you're
not providing enough value anymore
your business is not working and you
need to save it so you have to figure
out before you just figure out who to
fire and you look at their salaries
think about what is the new direction
that your company is gonna take how are
you gonna get through this downturn what
new products services value add are you
gonna provide to your customers or what
are you gonna take away because it's
just not working and once you figure out
your direction then you can figure out
who do I need on my team to make this
happen right if and if you're saying
that you know some things are not as
important anymore so if I was doing this
right for example if I looked at my
business
I might say you know what these videos
they take up too much of my time I'm not
making enough money from them anymore
and I need to cut I need to cut the
videos right if that was part of my plan
going forward then Christina would be a
casualty right of that sir Christina I
don't want to cut the videos but she
would be a casualty not because she's
not great but because I made a strategic
decision not to do videos anymore
so I think that's the better approach
for the companies it's not to look at
well who makes the most money and how
can I make the most savings it's
thinking about what projects that we're
gonna keep onboard
what's the future direction of our
business and then who do we need on our
current team to help us get there
and who who hopefully move on to better
things with their lives so it's kind of
a crappy topic to talk about man got me
a little depressed talking about firing
people but hopefully those those ideas
helped you and can help your clients
make better decisions believe for
everybody watching liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment you
have a question for me leave a comment
below I make a video response and if you
want to see more videos from me click on
my face you can subscribe to the channel
thank you so much and I'll see you soon